a powerful leader of the field is not
usually a descriptor for a woman
oftentimes a woman is described in terms
of her excellent teaching ability and
her mentoring but that's not considered
the attribute that leads to leadership
and scientific advances I like working
with men
I was raised with brothers I have no
sisters my laboratory for example is a
very consensus driven collaborative
laboratory it is not a traditional sort
of male organized structure and being
able to appreciate those differences and
value them I think is a very important
part of the advancement of our science
that being said I have no no hesitation
in reporting experiences of pretty
extraordinary discrimination and this
these types of discrimination events are
are benign in that they're not
intentional but they're probabilistic
that means that at every single decision
point that a woman scientist has she's a
little bit just a little bit more
vulnerable than a comprar male college
and when we look at the numbers they cry
for an explanation why is it that we
start as undergraduates now with as a
50-50 distribution of women in many of
the hard sciences
and there is this progressive attrition
of women to the hyrax
so that when we get to the tenure ranks
of a university what happens to all the
women well it's easy to give
explanations about you know life's
complexities family etc etcetera
etcetera that doesn't explain it if you
ask the women that that started out in
the trajectory and didn't make it even
if a woman does get tenure for example
she doesn't so often get the endowed
chair that is given to the more favored
colleagues which is oftentimes a man men
with endowed chairs
have better salary support because they
have money from the endowed chair the
woman doesn't and so even at the highest
ranks it is more difficult I think for
women scientists if you love the science
and if that's what you're born to do
then don't be discouraged by any of this
just go do it somehow they'll be away
sometimes you have to learn when not to
be too much of a lady so if you have to
kick ass just go do it that's what women
are going to have to do they're gonna
have to face that every once in a while
that you just sometimes got to be
tougher than you are it's important for
institutions to value their women let
their women know that they are valued
and to put put supports in place that
allow ambitious talented women to
contribute as best they can